help me out taking a second overall or
there two of them in
[Music]
there one male black gr hoodie blue
hands Crossing West get on the ground
get on the ground get on the ground get
down I
got you want to use this c that'd be
awesome we'll get it right back as soon
as we can yeah come on oh let's
let's we got an issue here okay okay
yeah you can take that out I would take
it along the river down by your buddy
all right he let me get this
he goes through yes to the right I see
something moving back there
too don't you see somebody yeah that's
our other officer we got two of them
okay so the fastest way out that way is
just go out one right here all right
sweet okay thank you we'll be right
back
you want to get on or you going to walk
I'll walk all right all
[Music]
right
fucking
am line right
now
yet to we have a
Dr oh we got one here in the let's wor
about him and then if you want to check
he was running was running towards the
riverest
area
in the areaway there's one in
there hey everybody this is a Morgan and
Morgan legal alert evidence shows that
Google has allegedly violated the
privacy of millions of Americans via
incognito mode your personal information
and data may have been unfairly
collected and then used for profit as
America's largest injury Law Firm Morgan
and Morgan has recovered over $20
billion in compensation for clients and
they may be able to help you fight for
justice if you've used incognito mode in
Google's Chrome internet browser you can
find out if you have a claim in only a
few clicks by visiting www.
forthepeople.com
LC gooogle it only takes a few minutes
to sign up and find out if you have a
claim
yeah yeah you need to get the fuck out
me out taking the second overall or
there two of them in
there come out crawl out dude don't do
anything
stupid get on the ground get on the
fucking
ground yeah right I'll show you you and
I I'll show you where he went in you
guys got him yeah we got him I'm not
fucking
touching one this way follow me I'll
show
you can I give him the U CH or uh in the
cart was it this is me I commer a cart
not
kidding start on you huh
are you injured at
all just scratching just a scratch on
your face you're good though smell like
shit 72 second is in custody yeah we got
myself checking the River Bank on west
or east side of the river
I
it
7:30 and 2 for 27 29
[Laughter]
check last name is STO s o TT Phillip is
the first name pH i l l i p that's what
everybody else J Johnson Middle male
black date of birth is 1118 of
[Music]
[Applause]
01 ready stand up one
two man that's thanks go this squad
right here you show you one of them no I
got to give it back to some
golfers